next month will mark a sad anniversary
that has already been 20 years since
Princess Diana died hard to believe and
to us she was the people's princess but
to William and Harry she was simply the
best mom in the world
[Music]
when everybody says to me you know so
she was fun
give us an example all I can hear is her
laugh in my head and that's sort of
crazy laughs of where there was just
pure happiness shown on her face in just
release photos and a new documentary
Princes William and Harry are sharing
their favorite childhood memories of
their mother last night they released
these private pictures from Diana's
personal photo album that's the boys
dressed as policemen and over the
weekend more never-before-seen images
that is Diana with William while she was
pregnant with Harry and William says one
of his favorite memories was a
supermodel surprise she organized Mike
came home from school to have Cindy
Crawford Christy Turlington and Miami
camera waiting it's up the stairs I was
probably 12 or 13 year old boy grabbed
posters thumbs walk and I went bright
red and didn't quite not would say and
sort of fumbled and I think I fell down
the stairs on the way out I was
completely enough me and sort of
awestruck the princes also talked about
their regret over their last phone call
with Diana she was in Paris and they
were enjoying playtime in Scotland
William said quote I think Harry and I
were just in a desperate rush to say
goodbye you know see you later and we're
going to go off if I'd known what was
going to happen I wouldn't have been so
close a the HBO documentary Diana our
mother her life and legacy which
premieres tonight on HBO also features
Elton John he's saying at Diana's
funeral and told Harry how she inspired
everyone around her I haven't
experienced many people in my life that
have that ability but she could walk
into a room of people and make them feel
as if everything was great
well that version of kennel in the wind
which Elton sang at the funeral he
donated all the proceeds to Diana's
charity